[Musique]
on va faire plusieurs défis dans la rue
à chaque fois que j'aurai un cadeau à
gagner le premier jeu il est très simple
ça sera pour benhaim savoir tout de
suite je vais évidemment alors le cadeau
en fait non il faut que je tire au sort
les cadeaux puisque je suis content
alors le cadeau tu vas pas jouer pour du
tout pour ce que je t'ai dit tu vas
jouer et si je l'avais senti un appareil
photo instantanée je l'avais senti je
l'avais senti fier c'est très beau de
tutelle ray ray lane
vous allez devoir mais peuvent sortir
dans la rue et partager un mikado avec
un bel inconnu avec sans les mains
d'accord chacun aux extrémités vous
allez arrêter quelqu'un dans la rue et
vous mangez un mikado comme ça jusqu'à
jusqu'à s'élève
yannick a donné comme sortir ou pas au
nom les autres listes non ça c'est tout
vous l'avez vous l'avez arrêter comme ça
là bas mais non je préfère ça va mieux
on nous a collé non non non
j'allais à la faute on y voit les
bourguignons elle en fera 2 à l'aller
moi je veux faire avec vous ces partis
parce que j'étais un homme je veux aller
loin a dit sa nana na na hey regardez
celle où l'état doit faire du studio
guillaume vasily novena on va jouer avec
ou là un ordinateur portable convertible
360 degrés j'aime bien ce qu'il va
falloir faire il va falloir faire
torse nu pour les garçons un car wash
s'y attendre et arrêté une voiture et
faire un carnage sexy ça peut être flic
ou garçon je fais tourner la roue
attention et je suis dedans oui je suis
dedans donc les gars tu peux être moi ça
peut être
[Applaudissements]
allez
tout le monde est en attrape
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais je me batte en valeur ce nu alors
il cela de la voiture et tu fais tu es
très sexy une journée très sexy ça tu
fais sexy mais je peux très sexy oui
alors on y va
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
partant
on est prévenu
sammarcelli
alors les cherry on va jouer pour la
zone cno il faut danser un zouk zouk
avec un moustachu au statut vous aurez
60 secondes pour tourner la moustache et
sa vallée chéri de seconde d'accord les
chéris je connais deux minutes je fais
on le fait comme ça on sait tous
ensemble ce sera toi qui verra le sou a
vécu le moustachu
non
[Applaudissements]
mathieu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci d'un bisou le bisou le bisou le
bisou le bisou sur la bouche
il assène t il
[Musique]